hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
are prototyping a more sustainable way
of living not sure how it's going to go
but let's see
and at this moment we're in a transition
phase where the days are getting shorter
winter is coming it's getting colder
more rain is coming basically living
autumn
and this means we have to do a few
things prepare ourselves a little bit
but it also comes with a few interesting
new opportunities like for instance
mushrooms here we have some mushrooms
they are the fruits of
autumn and wetland
rain is coming and it's announcing
different season and mushrooms are all
over the land
we personally don't know much about
mushrooms so we don't know which ones we
can eat
but it's just amazing to walk through
the land and discovering all the
different shapes and colors around trees
the soil grass wetlands
and
here are some shots of the mushrooms you
can see them and maybe you can help out
to see if there are some mushrooms we
can eat
[Music]
besides the mushrooms that have been
growing on the land also our plants have
been growing on the land a lot but these
ones were different because these ones
were planted by us six months ago in a
very small state
we have been drinking a lot of very
delicious fresh tea and now it's time to
chop them down dry the herbs and drink
also the tea during winter
[Music]
do
here we have our
harvest
our tea for the winter and we will dry
it up in the most decent roof we have
our land in our land
[Music]
and another harvest that needs to be
made is grape harvesting and the
neighbors ask for some help so adrien
and julie will go and help them
so today is vendima we are going to go
to our neighbors to great picking
we have never done it it looks super
exciting they gather all together is it
one day in a year that they do this
activity do it together it needs to be
fast
because the grapes are going to get bad
or if you go earlier they are not good
enough so today is the day to go great
picky
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
we already picked all the grapes now we
are gonna head the house of fernando
antonio to split the grapes from the
branches
and julie how was the day
it was very nice
we were
doing great baking for around three
hours with the neighbors and all their
friends because they all gathered
together to do this is kind of a group
activity
and they keep on going for the rest of
the day but we said that for now it's
enough
but yeah let's see the results in a
couple of months they will be done and
we can try them out so besides
harvesting things from the land another
thing which is atem is good for is to
start thinking about your forest because
it's a good moment to plant
trees but we don't know that much about
it especially not in this area and also
on a burned down land like what to do
with it
so on youtube we met this guy who
actually lives like 20 minutes away
and he bought a piece of land with his
family a few years ago and he's been
already recovering it hi
so welcome this is the quinta de vocenia
germano pian jo king and simon
we have moved to the
place in 2017 after a few years abroad
and we have been recovering it similar
to your wonderful project on the camp
and we like to share some lessons some
failures some curiosities about the land
and what we have been doing so far
when the forest
fire passes through one of our local
forests you have some trees that survive
and they survive because they are
mediterranean species they are used to
fire they are used to very high
temperatures
like this cork tree where the cork is
actually an envelope that protects them
from fire and they resist so they come
back after the fire and they they
survive
when it comes to the eucalyptus
plantations and they
burn at a very high temperature there's
nothing that stops the fire because they
they
are peripheral species so they actually
burn and enjoy the fire to make the
cleaning of the rest of the species and
to feed them basically so when they burn
like the forest that you see behind they
come back
very quickly and everything else becomes
asphyxiated in the forest
so it's your mission to remove the
eucalyptus and bring more native trees
back exactly so when we saw that
happening in 2017
our decision was bring back the native
species and take out the eucalyptus
systematically and from the roots so
eliminate them from
from the the land
we have done that in different stages so
the first stage was really to trade the
eucalyptus wood for the machinery to
actually lift up the stumps
the second stage was to restore some of
the trees that had survived the oaks the
cork trees and some of the chestnuts
trees and then the next stage was to
start populating or repopulating the
land with the seed or with planted trees
okay so first step
was to eliminate the eucalyptus and to
do that
before we actually got into
um
doing it we actually negotiate with a
few of the wood traders and we trade the
wood for the machinery to take at the
roots
so these are the roots of eucalyptus
some of the roots were a kilometer long
in the land close to
we had to dig
holes four meters deep for some of the
older eucalyptus to take them out and we
put them all here and now they are
housing for wild rabbits
in the pack it took one week to take one
hectare ever clipped this out
after the
extraction of all of the eucalyptus
roots we looked at the land and what had
survived the machinery movement
and also the summer because by then we
were at the end of the summer of 2017.
um and some of the trees like this cork
uh
tree survived from a burn stick that was
in the middle of the land completely
alone to actually green up the the
leaves and the branches the same
happened with the
strawberry trees with some of the oaks
that had burned
that cork tree also survived but got
completely carbonized it took a year or
so for it to get green again
[Music]
and it's still we have not taken the
cork out so it's still with the black
pork from the fire
next step after
recovering the trees we basically did a
bit of uh
desk planning we took some aerial photos
we had the topography of the land so the
levels and
different
lines
and we start looking at patterns of
planting in order to facilitate three
things one the wind and the fire
protection
to make sure that if we do did it had a
fire in the future there will be some
lines of fire cut which is the kind that
we built here it's a big separator um to
keep clean for fire prevention we looked
at
winter cold wind which comes down the
hill
and we looked at
water retention and for water retention
we use the kind of one main swale to
stop the water because it's very clay
soil to stop the water from washing down
and to keep some retain in here and from
that we start having major patterns
lines of planting and you can see how
the oaks are starting to recover along
the line
here
and we keep that also to facilitate
cleaning with a mulcher or with some
machinery that comes in so when it
mulches it mulches along the lines and
it doesn't damage the small trees that
are coming up
this was seated um this is a seeded
strip
yeah so this is a seeded
oak
from a seed that is probably two to
three years old
this is a sweet chestnut from seed as
well that was seated along the pattern
um
with the other trees
it's a tree that was seeded um and we
planted it in 2018 so it was just the
spring of 2018.
so it's three years old it's three years
old yeah and this area of the land is
the driest and the more challenging one
for the trees to thrive this is the end
of the summer is the harvest time so we
have some of the
cow peas which grow really well here
and from the forest what we get are the
chestnuts which start in september and
then different varieties all the way to
november
let me try to get one so you can
actually dry the
chestnuts and eat them as a candy
this is the sweet chestnut
[Music]
and this is nowhere for food we do
nothing to them yeah
uh we have the walnuts which were
just a simple
local
jubilance frail the local variety
and over there you have the
acorns that we picked up to bring to the
camp forest
for seeding and trying to get the
mimosas into oaks
it's um
you know it's a typical
harvesting from the sky you get it on
your head and it hurts
i noticed
the acorns are also used for
animal feed
the acorns for you to seed or to do a
nursery at your land at the camp
this is one variety of
oaks this is from another variety of the
oaks in the land and this is the biggest
acorn size
from another yet another type of oak
they are all pretty much the same
species but what we have noticed is that
they lose the leaves and they get the
leaves in the spring
at different timings
and that makes it interesting to manage
for example if you want to shade your
house or if you want to shade a
vegetable plot in the summer or if you
want to do some early spring planting
and you want those acorns those oaks
to be
have a variety that loses the leaf
earlier or later so back in our land and
now we have a lot of acorns
they have to go back to the land ideally
we would dig little holes and put them
inside but realistically
this will be the way we will do it
and hope for the best
besides working with seats there is also
cuts that we can do in the trees and
make them grow and this is what we did
with the willow tree
here we have a young willow tree and
it's super cool to have a bit of more
diversity on this land
and a few weeks ago freddie was here and
he found a branch on the floor and he
was making some cuttings out of the
branch he put them into a bucket with
water and how we have
little willow trees all around we will
just put them into the soil and hope for
the best to have a few more diverse
trees on the land
we don't know if this is going to become
a big tree or not but for now it's just
very good to plant new trees on the soil
[Music]
so another update we have to do is with
our energy storage we need to upgrade it
so a few updates ago you could see us
setting up our solar system so we have a
few panels on the roof then all the
electronics and a 10 kilowatt battery
pack to store all the electricity
but now to get ready for the winter we
need to upgrade and there are a few
reasons for that so one reason is that
we recently installed water system which
needs a pump to pump the water here
which takes electricity and originally
we thought this wouldn't be around here
on base camp because the water we will
find it somewhere else so we probably
need to have our own solar system
somewhere else just for the pump but
then we found water super close by so we
figured we could just put the pump to
the same system but the system wasn't
really designed for that for that
capacity um so due to having the water
pump we need to upgrade in the recent
days we had a few more people visiting
and we realized it kills up pretty
quickly if more people come
the usage goes up so it's kind of
inevitable that we just need to scale up
our battery pack
and the last one is also just really in
winter you have way more cloudy days so
you would harvest much less sun during
the day
or even a few days in a row which means
you just need to store it somewhere
otherwise you're not gonna have
electricity and it's actually fun i've
been observing a lot uh monitoring the
system and how it goes practically every
day is you get a lot of sun way more
than you can store
so the battery pack is full at around
five o'clock in the night then you stop
harvesting sun and slowly everything you
use from then on is just a battery pack
so it goes down down down down and in
the morning it's around fifty percent
usually with two people and then it goes
up again
so
that's kind of a recurring pattern but
if you have a few days in a row clouds
and that means it cannot recharge itself
so the next day you start at 50 percent
and it goes down again yeah we kind of
saw this problem coming as we scale up
so the thank you to what battery pack
right here there's place for exactly
another one of these which would just
double our capacity so i'm gonna do that
and then we should be good electricity
wise for the winter
so besides storing the energy we get
from our solar panels in our battery
there are also other ways to store this
energy and we actually installed
something new let me show you
it's an electric boiler to heat up the
water
uh
this thing right here we actually
already brought it uh
from netherlands so it's been here the
whole time but we just didn't hook it up
so what this does it basically just
heats up the water
but it's a good way to store extra
energy you have it into the water so
this is basically a big battery
and the main reason to do it is during
the day we just have a lot of moments
when we generate more electricity and
the battery is already full so you have
this extra energy you want to put into
something which is this thing
but what we don't want is to use this
thing um heating up overnight because
then it really uses the energy from the
battery and we wanted to use the energy
from the sun directly so we want to make
sure it only is turned on during the day
when the sun is shining so now we
actually
installed this timer so it only goes on
like at eight in the morning until four
in the afternoon when the sun is shining
however the ideal scenario would be that
it's linked to our solar setup so it
understands once the battery is full
only then we start charging or heating
up the water here
to make sure the battery always have
first priority and we can actually do
this with our current solar system it's
a victron energy servo gx so there's a
relation there that could turn on and
off but it needs to be programmed so
someone is interested let me know until
then i guess we use this one
yeah and the cool thing is besides just
storing all our energy that we harvest
we also just have hot water which also
means hot showers
yeah this is good
all right so that was it for this video
it's kind of nice actually to slowly get
ready for winter it's kind of a
different sad thing having a hot shower
and some cozy days but we still need to
get better prepared though because for
instance the pizza oven and the
container still need a roof to protect
us from the rain and we already had a
bunch of roof tiles but that's for the
next videos so if you want to see that
make sure to subscribe
that was it for now thanks for watching
see you in the next video